Federal Banking agencies like the FED
FDIC OCC
instructed financial institutions to
search Americans legal transactions in
attempts to surveil their purchases
while they're bringing in more of these
illegals right Janny Ellen wants to
bring in more to keep the labor force up
she also wants to uh make sure that uh
the government will be watching you
while you uh legally transact with your
friends and family however you might go
ahead doing that check this out at a
congressional hearing yesterday has
treasury including finsen or Federal
Banking agencies like the FED FDIC OCC
instructed financial institutions to
search Americans legal transactions in
attempts to surveil their
purchases well we received a letter from
you I believe on this topic and we
intend to investigate fully to respond
have you instructed banks financial inst
institutions to provide this
information well
finen job is to work with financial
institutions to make sure are they
instructing them financial institutions
to search Americans legal transactions
in attempts to surveil their
purchases I I promise a thorough look
into everything this is really
concerning lady are you the one who has
your job who might do something like
that so okay so we're getting a
non-answer as to whether the government
is telling your bank that it can look
into your financial transactions
nobody's doubting nobody's well I can't
say nobody's doubting you're allowed to
do with your money as you see fit and
you're allowed to buy things and and
you're allowed to lend money to people
and whatever else what why does the
government have allowed to put pressure
on banks so that they can just open up
the records on all of that and again I'm
connecting that to everything else
because they're constantly looking to
screw you right they want to take your
money and give 53 million in in credit
cards to feed these people while you are
doing whatever the hell it is that
you're doing and you have your right to
privacy and everything else and they
want to make sure that they can keep an
eye on you for that the next version of
of all of this of course is how they
will try to regulate uh crypto and
fortunately at least as it stands now
crypto which is end to endend in crypto
in technology so if you send Bitcoin to
somebody uh and it goes from your
Bitcoin wallet to their Bitcoin wallet
the government has no way of regulating
that but they're working on it uh and uh
here is Janet Yellen explaining to
Congress that uh they have got to figure
out a way to do that because God only we
can't have these people just buying a
sandwich for a friend we're the
government for God's sakes council is
focused on digital assets and related
risks such as runs such as from runs on
crypto asset platforms and stable coins
potential vulnerabilities from crypto
asset price
volatility and the proliferation of
platforms acting outside of or out of
compliance with applicable laws and
regulations applicable rules and
regulations should be enforced and
Congress should pass legislation to
provide for the regul of stable coins
and of the spot market for crypto assets
that are not Securities we look forward
to continuing to engage with Congress on
this with this overview I look forward
to taking your questions on you get the
point of all this why are they
constantly trying to find out more about
what you're doing and figuring out more
ways that they can regulate you and tax
you and make sure that you can't send
bitco coin to a friend without them
knowing why you did it right and it has
nothing to do with oh because the
government's just looking out you might
be doing something mean and you might be
selling drugs no no no no no you all
know it that's just the excuse to
control every little bit of your
life